here's an idea for you that i think the
world hasn't yet woken up to that uh
when i sit back and i say you know
what's a secret that investors if they
start to wrap their head around this
we'll start to change the way they
invest is uh we talk a lot about
commodities let's talk about oil and all
kinds of other commodities but actually
the world's most valuable commodity
right and if you go back to cleveland
and people realizing that this kerosene
and oil was going to be so
valuable before everybody else is
computing power is the world's most
valuable commodity and so ultimately
what bitcoin is backed by is the world's
strongest computing network right it is
backed by the strongest commodity in the
world it's the largest kind of computing
network commodity in the world and so i
think that what we're starting to see
and starting early where there's still a
lot of people wrap their head around
this is if you start to think of
computing power as a commodity and then
you start to say to yourself well who
owns the pipes to the computing power
well jeff bezos and aws is doing pretty
well yeah
the bitcoin network is backed by the
strongest computing network in the world
so it's truly our asset now right so you
start to start to look around and say
where's the computing power right where
is that pointed to who's providing it
who's the underlying infrastructure
that's making that possible i think that
that whole world and that whole economy
and industry is going to get really
really interesting pipes but but there's
another piece of it that gets me even
more excited which is if you look at
some of these companies like great
american mining and there's a whole slew
of them what they're doing is they're
saying we're going to connect that old
commodity world to the new uh commodity
world so they go out to the oil and gas
guys they say hey you guys are killing
the environment you guys are flaring all
this gas out here and it's one of the
most harmful things you can do but you
don't because you found oil what if we
could actually capture the flare gas and
we could turn it into power on site and
we could mine bitcoin right here whoa
and that's what they're doing is they're
literally powering bitcoin mining uh
equipment on site at the oil and gas uh
kind of uh wellhead and they're
capturing flare gas and they're mining
because all you have to do is have an
internet connection in these machines
all right
i just stopped yourself all right so
i'm meeting with the ceo coca-cola
and i said how much you pay for the
carbon dioxide he tells me prices and i
get why don't we take all the carbon
dioxide that comes out of the wells when
they drill and we'll send it to
coca-cola here's the way i'm thinking
i'm thinking about a soft drink you're
thinking about bitcoin and that is the
difference but you see after this
interchange i know enough with what the
co2 in the coca-cola you've got an idea
that is brilliant
tomorrow next time i'm gonna say what
the hell
why why can't you diversify like this or
every company
every single company in the world that
has any sort of power generation is
going to do this because the financial
incentive is way too high every day
right now bitcoin miners are paid like
50 to 55 million dollars all around the
world every day so we're talking about
you know billions and billions of
dollars in terms of annual revenue to
bitcoin miners right but the beauty is
that you don't have to go buy equity in
a minor to get that exposure exxon said
hey you know what we got a lot of gas
flaring going on we got a lot of access
to power why don't we just buy some of
these computers plug them in and then
we'll start to get our own fair share of
that revenue you would see that not only
are these companies going to have what a
lot of people are referring to like a
michael saylor referred to as a treasury
strategy all right how do i go ahead and
buy bitcoin and put it on my balance
sheet and kind of use that to protect my
shareholder value but also what they're
going to start to say is wait a second i
need a p l strategy how do i actually
participate in this economy and drive
revenue and profits off of this and so i
think that ultimately the financial
incentive for this system is going to be
incredible it's just that people are
uneducated yet they've spent the time
right if you're running exxon this last
thing in your mind is how do i mine it
no
over time though that changes like
rockefeller you just gotta think like
rockefeller who was this bumpkin but he
had thoughts like this he if he wouldn't
be rolling over his grave right now he
would be saying you know what i want to
go right now and ring the neck of the
exxon guy that he hasn't thought about
it or worse that he thinks it's small
of course that's what the people felt
were the refineries the 27 clever
fighters they thought they were small
but when you took them together oh my
god well anyway look i gotta go shoot i
gotta go like
oh man i gotta go lose money versus make
money
you are pure joy
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time